i've seen the word misinformation
misused or used as a bullying word like
racism and so on which are
important
concepts to identify but they're
nevertheless
instead overused yes um does that worry
you because that seems to be the
mechanism
from inside twitter from inside facebook
to label information you don't like
versus information that's
actually
fundamentally harmful to society yeah so
i think there is um there is a meaning
of disinformation that is very useful
and and helpful
um which is when you have a concerted
campaign by russian agents
um to plant a story and spread it and
they've been doing that since the 50s or
40s even um that's what this podcast
actually is but
it's a disinformation yeah you seem
really soviet to me buddy
um
it's subtle it's between the lines
okay i'm sorry but uh um so i think it
went to the extent that there are
campaigns uh by either foreign agents uh
or you know just by the republican or
democratic parties there have been
examples of that um
there are all kinds of concerted
campaigns
that are intending to uh to confuse or
spread lies
this is the the soviet the firehose of
falsehood tactic
so it's very useful for that all the
companies need to have pretty large
staffs i think to deal with that because
that will always be there and that um is
really bad for our country uh so rene
deresta um is just brilliant on this i
reading her work has really frightened
me and opened my eyes about how easy it
is to manipulate um to manipulate and
spread
misinformation and especially um
polarization the russians have been
trying for the since the 50s
they would come to america and they
would do hate crimes they would spray
you know swastikas and synagogues to
make you know in this way anti-black
slurs they try to make americans feel
that they're as divided as possible
most of the debate nowadays however is
not that it seems to be people are
talking about what the other side is
saying so
um you know if you're on the right then
you're very conscious of the times when
well you know the left wouldn't let us
even say
could covet be from a lab like they
would like you literally would get shut
down for saying that and it turns out
well we don't know if it's true but
there's at least a real likelihood that
it isn't it certainly is something that
should have been talked about so
i tend to stay away from any such
discussions um and the reason is twofold
one is because they're almost entirely
partisan it generally is each side
thinks that what the other side is
saying is fate is is his
misinformation or disinformation and
they can prove certain examples um so
we're not going to get anywhere on that
we certainly are never going to get 60
votes in the senate for anything um
about that i don't think content
moderation is nearly as important as
people think has to be done and it can
be improved
almost all the action is in the dynamics
the architecture the virality uh and
then the nature of who uh who is on the
platform you know unverified people and
how much amplification they get that's
what we should be looking at rather than
wasting so much of our breath on whether
we're gonna do a little more or little
less content moderation so the true harm
to society
on average and over the long term is in
the dynamics is it it's fundamentally in
the dynamics of social media not in the
subtle choices of content moderation aka
censorship exactly they've always been
conspiracy theories you know the turner
diaries is this book written in 1978 it
uh it introduced the the replacement
theory to a lot of people um timothy
mcveigh had it on him when he was
captured in 1995 after the oklahoma city
bombing it's a kind of a bible of that
that fringe violent racist
uh white supremacist
group
and that um so you know the the the
killer in buffalo was well acquainted
with these ideas they you know they've
been around but you know this guy's from
a small town i forget where he's from uh
you know but he was and he says in a
manifesto um he was entirely influenced
by things he found online he was not
influenced by anyone he met in person
um
ideas spread and communities can form
these like micro communities
can form with bizarre and twisted
beliefs
um and this is again back to the the
atlantic article i've got this amazing
quote from martin guri let me just find
it but he martin guri he was a former
cia analyst wrote this brilliant book
called the revolt of the public or um
and he has this
great quote he says he talks about how
um
in the age of mass media we were all in
a sense looking at a mirror looking back
at us and it might have been a distorted
mirror but we had stories in common we
had facts in common um it was mass media
and he describes how the flood of
information with the internet uh is like
a tsunami washing over it has all kinds
of effects and he says
this isn't a comment in an interview in
vox he says
the digital revolution has shattered
that mirror and now the public inhabits
those broken pieces of glass so the
public isn't one thing it's highly
fragmented and it's basically mutually
hostile it's mostly people yelling each
other and living in bubbles of one sort
or another and so you know we now see
clearly there's there this little bubble
of of just bizarre you know nastiness
in which you know the killer in christ
church and the killer in norway and now
in buffalo you know they're all put into
a community and posts flow up within
that community by a certain dynamic
so we can never stamp
those words or ideas out the question is
not
can we stop them from existing the
question is
what platforms what are the platforms by
which they spread all over the world
into every little town so that the one
percent of whatever whatever percentage
of young men are vulnerable to this that
they they get exposed to it it's in the
dynamics in the architecture
it's a fascinating point to think about
because we often
debate and think about the
the content moderation the censorship
the ideas of free speech but you're
saying
yes that's important to talk about but
much more important is fixing the
dynamics that's right because everyone
thinks if there's regulation it means
censorship at least people on the right
think regulation equals censorship and
i'm trying to say no no that's only if
all we talk about is content moderation
well then yes that is the framework you
know how much or how little do we you
know but i don't want to talk about that
because all the action is in the
dynamics that's the point of my article
it's the architecture changed and our
social world went insane
you